oui à
l'étranger concrétiser ses promesses
tout en conservant le royaume ni pour
david cameron c'est mission accomplie le
premier ministre britannique avait
promis aux écossais plus de pouvoir
s'ils votaient non au référendum raymond
vous étiez à edimbourg lors de ce
référendum justement c'est cette
promesse de plus de pouvoir ça a
beaucoup joué alors là londres tient
parole mais en partie mais vous en
souvenez dans les derniers jours de la
campagne ces promesses l'abbé avait fait
que le oui avait atteint un plateau dont
il n'a pas bougé puis finalement c'est
le non qui l'emporté après on a créé une
commission commission suite pour faire
des propositions de changements des
changements là qui ont été acceptées par
les partis politiques à londres par le
monde mais ce ministère mais aussi au
parlement écossais par exemple on va
accorder à l'ecosse le pouvoir de lever
l'impôt sur le revenu et de l'utiliser à
sa guise 60 milliards de dollars ça
c'est énormément d'argent pouvoir aussi
d'assurer la protection des programmes
sociaux programme soit plus généreux
donc comme ils voulaient les écossais et
troisièmement contrôle de la législation
électorale par exemple accorder le droit
de vote aux jeunes de 16 comme on l'a
fait durant le référendum donc c'est
considérable n'empêche que ça fait des
mécontents un peu des deux côtés
nicholas ray jones qui a pris la tête
maintenant du snp le parti
indépendantiste au pouvoir dit elle bat
c'est bien plus de pouvoir mais
l'indépendance 10les beaucoup mieux en
général dans la presse britannique on
s'inquiète aussi du fait que les autres
composantes du royaume uni pays de
galles irlande du nord l'angleterre où
on voit ça arrive et ils vont débat nous
aussi on veut la même chose et ce sera
difficile de le redire non donc à la
longue on voit un affaiblissement du
pouvoir du gouvernement central un
affaiblissement du royaume et ne
s'inquiète oui merci raymond aparis nous
en parler